we've got a lot of news to get to we
begin with that breaking news though it
is from the central part of the valley
yeah crews are on the scene of a fire
now eastern end sahara we have hector
mejia live just on the scene with the
latest details hector good morning to
you
hey there good morning probably not the
best way to wake up this morning with
flashing lights and investigators in
your driveway let's give you a live look
this is terrytown complex we walked up
there just a few minutes ago
before police pulled up crime tape from
what we can see from a distance there
was a fire here in or near a garage and
now we have
multiple jurisdictions here we have
metro police we have las vegas fire and
rescue as well as clark county fire
department
as far as any injuries we don't know yet
we were told that the battalion chief
would walk out here to give us
additional information but
part of the driveway here at this
complex blocked off this morning after a
report of a fire
in terms of any lane closures or the
impact for the traffic in the area
just in the last few minutes the fire
trucks that were blocking eastern
northbound just after karen
left so it's no longer impacting traffic
in the area but as far as
this complex goes a portion of it is
blocked off as investigators just
arrived
also in the last 30 minutes to start
looking into what started this fire in
the first place
but that's the latest from the scene
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys